i've already seen that in scandinavia
it's 20 to one
female nurses
to male something like that it might not
be quite that extreme and approximately
the same male engineers female engineers
and that's a consequence of the free
choice of men and women in the societies
that have gone farther than any other
societies to make gender equality the
purpose of the law those are interracial
differences you can eradicate them with
tremendous social pressure and tyranny
but if you leave men and women to make
their own choices you will not get equal
outcomes right so you're saying that
anyone who believes in equality whether
you call them feminists call them
whatever you want to call them should
basically give up because it ain't gonna
happen only if they're aiming at
equality of outcome
so you're saying give people equality of
opportunity that's fine
not only fine it's eminently desirable
for everyone because we're just told
from such a young age like there's this
like pay gap and like we're a prep yeah
we are and men aren't like they don't
complain you know